To solve this problem, we want to use power divided by root for each of our
factors. So for x we'll have 7 divided by 3. For y we'll have 5 divided by 3.
And for z we'll have 10 divided by 3. Since 7 divided by 3 is 2 remainder 1,
we'll have x squared on the outside and x to the 1 on the inside of our cubed
root. For y, we'll have 1y on the outside and we'll have y squared left on the
inside. And finally for z, we'll have z cubed on the outside, and 1z on the
inside of our cube root. This is our final result. We could have also
completely expanded this radicand. Once we have all the factors listed out, we
want to find the factors that appear three times. That means we can pull it
out. Here's a group of three xs. And here's a group of three xs. So we can pull
out an x and an x. We can also pull out one y, and we can pull out three zs.
These other factors don't appear in a triple, so we leave them inside of our
cube root. X, y squared, z. And finally, we just rewrite the front part of our
radical to get x squared y z cubed times the cubed root of xy squared z.